hello there I'm John Oliver look it's
the middle of October which across the
nation means that we are all looking at
this and thinking I don't know why but I
simply have to drink that yes it's that
special time of year where we
voluntarily imbibe pumpkin spice lattes
the coffee that tastes like a candle and
and I don't mean it tastes like a candle
smells pumpkin spice lattes tastes like
a candle tastes don't ask me how I know
that but what is strange is that pumpkin
spice foods
inexplicably seem to grow more
omnipresent every year even though
there's no actual pumpkin in the drinks
kind of like how everyone you meet calls
himself a DJ all of a sudden when what
they really mean is that they own an
iPad and have been to a party but
apparently each American eats more than
5 pounds of pumpkin per year which is
more than the amount of pumpkin in 5
pumpkin pies and pumpkin pie is the most
seasonal food that there is it is only
good from the moment Thanksgiving dinner
ends until just after you have taken
your first bite of it 5 pounds of
pumpkin a year is even crazier than the
fact that we allegedly swallow eight
spiders in a lifetime why is it crazy
because there is no way a pumpkin has
ever crawled into my mouth while I was
sleeping
and the worst part is nobody wants
anything pumpkin-flavored
from December through August and here is
how I know that you can have it whenever
you want that bottle pumpkin flavored
science goo sits behind the counter of
Starbucks all year round never aging
like Ryan Seacrest or the early work of
dr. Dre which which really holds up it
really holds up have you listened to the
chronic lately go back and do it it's
really great if it's great except for
these sexism and homophobia which is
most of it but that's not the point
it's really good the point is we
tolerate pumpkin spice because we like
the fall it's the best season because
you get to stop thinking about how weird
your legs look in shorts that is Everett
that's everyone right we all agree on
that but just about anything that
reminds us of autumn is a better flavor
than pumpkin spice I personally for
instance would rather drink a cable knit
sweater spice latte or a major league
baseball spice latte or a keen awareness
of my own mortality spice latte because
that's what foliage is although look it
might be the quiet types that might be
the quiet times pumpkin spice is just
eggnog for morning people okay and I
will be subject to its Turrentine no
longer it stops here we'll be back next
week with a brand new episode of last
week tonight until then please ignore
the news and continue to drink regular
coffee good night
[Applause]